c'est quoi ça non mais c'est une
météorite
tu fais quoi avec un autre dieu ni toi
hein quoi est mort voir la météorite
mais on dit que c'est une pierre magique
et ça ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire
qu'il a déjà rendu non mais arrête tes
gluck et non mais le mec a avalé un
caillou c'est fou quand même
non mais attends est quand même plus
intéressant qu'un mec qui avait alain
caillau parce qu'il fait un bad trip a
retrouvé le bon sens ça marrant mais
capable à un caillou man of the unit
better et il avalé une météorite en plus
dense encore plus marrant je suis
vraiment désolé pour ce mec là mais il
ya quand même des choses plus
intéressantes qui se passe dans le monde
en afrique en asie documentez-vous cm du
bon coin c'est notre caillou qu'il a
avalé quoi tu vois que c'est pas si
inintéressant les faits divers
[Musique]
je ne vais pas vous jeter la pierre moi
aussi j'ai une fascination pour les
faits divers un peu glauque mon
historique peut en témoigner
j'ai énormément lu sur les tueurs en
série les faits divers un peu médiatisé
bref si la police a accès en historique
wikipédia je pense qu'il ne faut pas que
je tarde à planifier ma fille va à
l'étranger
la question qu'il faut se poser plutôt
que de se culpabiliser c'est pourquoi
pourquoi aime-t-on autant les faits
divers pourquoi aime-t-on autant lire
des articles qui nous donne des détails
dont on se passerait bien puisque ce
n'est clairement pas de l'information
dont on peut faire quelque chose
il n'y a qu'à voir le succès des faites
entrer l'accusé affaires criminelles ou
les documentaires sur l' affaire grégory
lui kamanyola et j'en passe ça soulève
beaucoup de questions mais qu'est ce qui
relève du fait divers et qu'est ce qui
n'en relève pas un fait divers c'est un
événement plus ou moins importants qui
ne relèvent ni de l'actualité mondiale
ou de la politique ni de l'économie on
peut regrouper deux dans les accidents
les catastrophes naturelles les
enlèvements les meurtres etc
pour info en argot journalistique on
appelle ça un chien écrasé le feu
d'hiver c'est un peu ce papier que l'on
trouve dans les journaux ou sur internet
sur lequel on n'a pas forcément beaucoup
de détails et qu'il n'est pas toujours
repris par la suite
et puis des fois certains faits divers
font l'objet d'une couverture médiatique
plus importante foire pour des questions
de timing
par exemple plus grave accident de tgv
en france a été passé quasi sous silence
puisqu'il s'est produit en même temps
que les attentats du bataclan là c'est
assez compréhensible mais parfois les
raisons d'une médiatisation importante
sont un petit peu plus mystérieuse par
exemple si je vous dis mère infanticide
vous allez probablement pensé en premier
à véronique courjault condamnée pour
trois infanticides
mais vous ne penserez peut-être pas à
dominique cottrez qui a été médiatisé
aussi mais qui est moindre essai d'un
imaginaire collectif
alors qu'elle a été condamnée pour huit
infanticides du coup à partir de quand
un fait divers et il présentait comme un
fait de société ce serait les médias qui
en fonction de leur traitement et de
l'importance dans la presse ferait
basculer le fait divers au fait tout
court
[Musique]
alors je vais pas vous apprendre combien
on a une fascination pour le hors norme
puisque mon coloc que vous l'a déjà
expliqué n'a pas du tout pas du tout tu
dis toujours c'est des monstres en plus
c'est dénonce du tout mais n'importe
quoi ces démons
oui on a tendance à être fasciné par
globalement tout ce qui sort de la norme
les criminels nous semble très éloignée
de nous on se dit qu'on ne connaîtrait
jamais de telles atrocités
on cherche à comprendre leur état
d'esprit ce qui les pousse à passer à
l'acte ces personnes mettent à mal notre
idée de cohésion de la société d'ordre
public et ça c'est une notion très
juridique
d'où notre fascination à leur égard et
notre fascination provoque parfois des
réactions assez forte comme lorsqu on
les qualifie de monstre par exemple
marqué une telle opposition ça permet de
créer un sentiment de supériorité
ces hommes de la force à des discours
qui vont considérer que la violence ou
la torture à l'égard des bourreaux et
légitime voire souhaitable et sabah en
tant que juriste vous comprendrez bien
que ça me chiffonne un petit peu le
souci c'est qu'employé le terme de
monstres est une façon de les
déshumaniser ça les éloigne notre
condition d'être humain
ça entretient l'idée qu'on est criminel
alors que l'aube allemand on a plutôt
tendance à le devenir du coup ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui va vraiment nous
aider à comprendre ce qu'il se passe
dans la tête d'un criminel alors que
c'est le résultat d'une multiplicité de
facteurs dont des facteurs
socioculturels et sabah dans la presse
on n'en parle pas suffisamment
déjà parce que ça devient un petit peu
technique et puis ça fait moins réagir
et le problème c'est que cette
fascination pour le glauque et le
morbide donc pour satin fait divers à
des effets secondaires assez importance
notre société les faits divers occupe
une grande place dans l'actualité parce
qu'ils font vendre qu'il génère du clic
et de l'engagement
il ya tout un processus narratif autour
des faits puisqu'on retrouve des
éléments comme une situation initiale un
élément perturbateur différents
protagonistes
on ne sait pas encore tout des mystères
restent encore à éclaircir
que s'est il passé exactement qui est le
coupable est at il agi seul pour quelles
raisons et certains documentaires au
reportage ne varie pas beaucoup de la
fiction puisque on retrouve le même
schéma de narration vont vous sous notre
corde sensible avec de la mise en scène
une musique dramatique le besoin encore
de christophe hondelatte et c'est
peut-être cela qui nous rend si réceptif
on peut donc dire que les feux d'hiver
captent notre attention s'il génère de
l'argent on va forcément les mettre en
avant
du coup on va plus avoir tendance à
consommer cette information et paf c'est
un peu un cercle
messieurs mais ça vous le savez déjà
sauf que pour vendre l'information
exclusive et des détails croustillants
la presse prend parfois des risques
inconsidérés
on se souvient bien sûr de la sphère du
petit grégory ou bernard laroche avait
été inculpé en quasi direct à la télé
est proclamée comme l'assassin de
l'enfant sans trop respecter la
présomption d'innocence
pour rappel la présomption d'innocence
c'est le fait de considérer qu'une
personne est innocente tant qu'elle n'a
pas été condamné par un tribunal pour
ses actes d'où l'utilité d'utiliser
présumé et de réviser son conditionnel
de façon plus récentes on se souvient
aussi de l'attentât de l'hyper cacher en
janvier 2015 ou bfm tv avait révélé que
satan otages s'étaient réfugiés dans la
chambre froide
une information qui aurait pu mettre en
péril leur sécurité si elle était
parvenue aux terroristes merci bfm dans
le même genre est toujours chez bfm
décidément on à ce titre complètement
délirant qui a dû tourner en boucle à
l'époque attentes à ce que les
terroristes ont dit à bfm tv
oui parce que bfm a tenté de joindre des
témoins alors que les terroristes
s'étaient retranchés dans l'imprimerie
sauf qu'il y avait un otage encore une
fois et ça aurait pu terriblement mal
tourné le média notamment les chaînes
télé d'infos en continu film parfois les
assauts des forces de police pour mettre
fin aux prises d'otages at on vraiment
besoin de cette information en direct
qu'est ce que ça nous apporte à part du
voyeurisme le direct n'est par
définition pas prévisible il a des aléas
et nous sommes comme spectateur devant
notre télé où notre fil d'actualité d'un
réseau social quelconque s'il est
tentant d'être informés au plus vite
pour être coeur de l'action et de
l'actualité il ne faudrait pas consommer
ce type d'information de la même façon
qu'un divertissement
bon je vais pas tirer sur l'ambulance
car les médias se sont un peu fait tirer
les oreilles par l'opinion publique et
les autorités après dit-elle quoique
mais je pense qu'on sera tous
relativement d'accord pour dire que ces
comportements ne doivent surtout pas
être reproduits m'enfin quand même on
n'avait peut être pas besoin
d'expérimenter le truc pour se rendre
compte que ça posait de sacrés problèmes
je sais pas moi ce qui me chagrine aussi
très fort c'est que les faits divers
sont souvent traitées rapidement avec
des grosses des énormes erreurs de droit
pourquoi parce que les journalistes sont
aussi tenus par des objectifs de
rentabilité
ils doivent publier vite ils n'ont pas
forcément le temps d'approfondir le
sujet autant qu'il le voudrait on ne
peut pas totalement leur jeter la pierre
puisque après tout ils n'ont
à tous une formation de juriste et
autant vous dire que cinq ans sur les
bancs de la fac ne suffisent pas pour
faire de vous un bon juriste
alors si en plus vous n'avez pas fait
une formation spécialisée dans le droit
forcément les papiers ne seront pas
toujours rigoureux malheureusement non
parce que des fois votre manque de
rigueur c'est insupportable oui bah bon
on fait ce qu'on peut mais est ce qui
aurait pas un biais cognitif qui craque
on se souviendra un peu plus de bas des
égarements journalistique parce que
quand on regarde bien il ya quand même
une énorme masse de contenus qui sont
produits chaque jour quoi on n'est pas
on n'est pas des grands méchants nous
les journalistes on fait ce qu'on peut
pour pour essayer de bien faire notre
boulot quoi parce qu'on a une éthique
bon après y'a franchement une charte qui
existe c'est la charte de munich c'est
là en gros la référence en déontologie
journalistique à l'échelle européenne et
elle nous dit que la mission
d'information comporte nécessairement
des limites que les journalistes
eux-mêmes s'impose spontanément quand
bronze c'est vraiment laissée à
l'appréciation de chacun il ya un espèce
de flou artistique quand on est si sûre
après il ya tout un truc autour du scoop
il ya vraiment enfin quand tu t'engages
en journalisme en général les gens qui
se sentent investis d'une mission c'est
un peu pour faire leur élise lucet pour
découvrir des choses pour faire changer
le monde et du coup bas le scoop ça
s'inscrit complètement dans cette dans
cette logique la couarde et moi même
j'ai expérimenté
c'est un exemple un peu nul mais j'ai
passé une nuit blanche pour sortir une
info avant tout le monde pourra vraiment
scoop est en fait c'était juste pour
dire qu'on avait retrouvé un squelette
d'un éléphant d'une espèce disparue en
france et j'étais trop fier de moi mais
je me dis est ce que ça vaut le coup
quand même de passer une nuit blanche à
travailler pour sortir cette info qui a
été oubliée dès le lendemain de quoi
mais de toute façon je sais pas si ça
vaut vraiment le coup de taper sur les
journalistes parce que c'est vraiment le
dernier maillon de la chaîne
en fait c'est tout le système qui est
pourri parce qu'il ya vraiment une
course à la rentabilité et on doit
produire toujours plus malin et quand tu
dois faire deux trois quatre cinq six
articles par jour
forcément tu as pas le temps de bien
creuser et rechercher les informations
et tous après heureusement c'est pas
pareil partout dans tous les médias
perso j'ai eu beaucoup de chance de ce
côté là mais c'est vrai que à mon avis
le problème c'est de trouver un modèle
économique viable pour la presse parce
qu'à l'heure actuelle la plupart des
titres de presse sont complètement à
perd 3 mais en fait le problème c'est le
capitalisme le lexique je vais revenir
mais déjà on pourrait parler berne
par idriss est un créatif à l'épisode
d'avant sur la pub mensongère parce que
bah déjà ouais tu peux utiliser du
conditionnel des adverbes comme
probablement peut-être ce genre de truc
genre de construction pour rajouter des
hypothèses ou des théories qui sont
absolument pas du tout étayé mais qui
permettent un peu devant le truc un peu
plus glauque peu plus voyeur donc ça ça
mange pas de pain puis c'est quelque
chose d'assez régulier d'ailleurs les
gens retiennent souvent ces genres de
choses
et oui en terme de lexie quoi y'a des
trucs et des trucs c'est vraiment tu
sais que si c'est là tu sais qu'il ya eu
un délire genre garçonnet quoi si tu as
ta le mot garçonnet dans un article que
tu sais que le gamin il a mal fini quoi
il a peut-être finir dans la vologne
schéma où il a fini il a fini tu es ou à
la ben tu sais pas mais jamais tu vas
dire vraiment là je suis allé chercher
pas avec mon garçonnet jamais tu parles
comme ça tu es enfant par exemple pareil
tu vas jamais j'ai pas chez casto je
sais pas quoi jeter à corps de halle est
un mec qui vient jeter la cordelette
fois que les dix-sept quoi enfin c'est
moi la cordelette ça c est rattaché un
cadavre attaché un garçonnet
éventuellement quoi même pas eu une
fille être la fille est pour moi c'est
la petite fille qui a vécu un petit coup
dur quoi c'est pas c'est jamais à banon
mais je sais que ma petite fille est
l'annoncé jamais jamais et du coup si tu
as un gala qu'est dans ce cas la
caravane et qui veut acheter de l'accord
de l'etec à un garçon et une fillette à
l'arrière battue c'est déjà de base que
c'est un fait divers ou une affaire
judiciaire ou en tout cas un truc pas
terrible du coup ces faits divers
entretiennent notre méconnaissance du
droit car on n'a pas vraiment le temps
de faire de la vulgarisation en même
temps on ne peut pas expliquer la
procédure parce que c'est une discipline
complexe et exigeante
on ne peut pas prendre le temps
d'expliquer la différence entre un
assassinat est un homicide volontaire
alors que c'est pourtant une distinction
ultra importante banon un assassinat
c'est forcément prémédité et un homicide
volontaire c'est pas toujours prémédité
et ses informations parcellaires rapide
entraîne un peu l'idée d'une justice
laxiste qui laisserait les criminels
dans la nature et ne condamnerais cas
des peines symboliques
on ne prend pas le temps d'expliquer
pourquoi on décide de recourir à un
bracelet électronique
pourquoi on fait une remise de peine ou
pourquoi après un appel on relâche le
présumé alors qu'il avait été condamné
quelques années plus tôt toutes ces
informations vont créer une
aux fusions dans la tête des gens qui
vont souvent avoir tendance à être
énervé face aux décisions de justice
dont ils ont eu vent car il ne les
comprennent pas et loin de moi l'idée de
les culpabiliser car c'est normal une
décision de justice quand on n'est pas
juriste c'est tout simplement impossible
à comprendre et les médias ne peuvent
pas retranscrire dans son intégralité la
complexité du dossier il faut juste
garder en tête que s'il y a eu plusieurs
années d' enquête plusieurs jours de
procès et des questions d'interprétation
de la règle de droit
aucun article de presse non spécialisée
ne peut retranscrire toute la complexité
de ce dossier et on ne peut pas se faire
un avis sans avoir assisté au procès et
avoir tenu le dossier entre les mains
enfin on peut avoir son avis mais il
faut rester prudent sur cette question
et ne pas considérer que les juges en
mal fait leur travail car c'est un peu
insultant pour eux vu le temps qu'ils y
passent et vu l'étendue des informations
dont il dispose du coup cette idée
préconçue une justice laxiste entretient
la crise de confiance qu'ont les
français dans l'institution judiciaire
bon c'est quand même ballot et c'est
même très inquiétant puisque ce sont
peut-être des personnes qui vont se
détourner de notre justice
institutionnelle soit en ne faisant rien
alors qu'elle pourrait peut-être obtenir
gain de cause
soit en se faisant justice elle même la
multiplication des faits divers est
particulièrement lorsqu'ils sont
violents vont aussi amener les individus
à réclamer une justice plus répressives
bref aucune de ces solutions n'est
réellement satisfaisante
[Musique]
l'autre versant de cette image d'une
justice laxiste c'est qu'on a tendance à
totalement surévalué la criminalité ce
qui rejoint le biais de négativité
c'est à dire qu'on accorde plus
d'attention aux informations négatives
on les retient mieux que le positif et
ça vous et moi on aura du mal à avoir un
contrôle dessus
sauf que statistiquement les faits
divers et autres crimes abominables ne
sont qu'une toute petite partie des
infractions global trg et quand on
regarde la presse c'est pas du tout
l'impression qu'on a on a même le
sentiment que c'est plutôt inverse en
2013 li na a même estimé que le nombre
de faits divers dans les jt a augmenté
de 73% en dix ans et pourtant notre taux
de criminalité n'a pas du tout suivi la
même courbe un je vous rassure
au contraire même puisque on voit une
sacrée chute de statistiques pour 1000
habitants on passe d'un taux de 68,9 en
2002 à 54 6 en 2012 d'ailleurs le
ministère de la justice publie chaque
année les statistiques concernant le
nombre d'infractions pénales et je vous
conseille au passage dit faire un tour
parce que c'est une mine d'or
d'informations
vous retrouverez toutes ses sources dans
la description on y apprend que pour
l'année 2018 par exemple on recense un
peu moins de 2300 crime pour 545 1000e
délit bon alors c'est pas si étonnant
puisque la catégorie des délits elle
regroupe beaucoup plus d'infractions
pénales différentes que les crimes mais
quand même ça fait un facteur
multiplicateur de 237 séparions petit
récap rapide aux du juriste en herbe
en france on regroupe tout nos
infraction pénale en trois catégories
par ordre de gravité
les contraventions qui vont du tapage
nocturne à l' injure non publique en
passant par le fait de ne pas avoir de
ticket de métro
les délits qui regroupe des infractions
plus graves que les contraventions et il
y en a énormément diffamation en public
violences volontaires agressions
sexuelles abus de biens sociaux et
sachez au passage que l'homicide
involontaire est un délit et non pas un
crime parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
intention de tuer pour que ce soit
considéré comme un crime et donc la
catégorie la plus grave les crimes
forcément si c'est la catégorie la plus
grave on doit la réserve et à quelques
infractions seulement sinon la
hiérarchie aurait moins de sens dans les
crimes on retrouve le vol à main armée
le viol la réduction en esclavage le
meurtre les génocides
bref toutes les infractions les plus
violentes et les plus attentatoires à
notre intégrité physique ou à notre
dignité
bref plein de joyeusetés diverses et
variées donc comme je vous disais pour
l'année 2018 2300 crime pour 545 mille
délit bon c'est beaucoup en soit je dis
pas le contraire
et puis on compte pas tous ceux qui sont
passés sous silence mais quand même
notre taux de délinquance et de
criminalité n'est pas en pleine
explosion
et malheureusement les médias ont plutôt
tendance à laisser penser le contraire
et en surévaluant le nombre de faits
divers surtout les plus sanguinaires est
terrible cela entretient un sentiment
d'insécurité qui est bien au dessus des
réalités statistiques et on ne peut pas
nier effectivement que dans certaines
villes il y a plus de délits et de
crimes qu'ailleurs c'est vrai mais c'est
dû à d'autres critères comme la pauvreté
l'exclusion le chômage etc
ce qui est rarement pris en compte comme
il se doit par les médias parce qu'on ne
va pas en plus s'emmerder avec la
sociologie
plus sérieusement il est complexe
expliquait ses grandes problématiques
sociales
elle mobilise beaucoup de connaissances
différentes elle demande de croiser
plein de sources d'expliquer différents
points de vue qui parfois se
contredisent parce que bas dans les
sciences sociales on n'est pas toujours
d'accord
le journal télévisé ou les petites
brèves de presse ne peuvent pas faire le
travail d'un documentaire long et
complexe
accessible à tous et ce n'est pas ce
qu'on leur demande mais on pourrait
éventuellement repenser la place qu'on
offre à ces documents de fonds aux
heures de grande écoute
bon alors on a parlé de la
responsabilité de la presse de la
surévaluation de la criminalité et de la
crise de confiance que pouvaient avoir
les jambes pour l'institution mais
concrètement chez les juristes ça se
passe comment les faits divers et ben
c'est très embêtant on va pas se mentir
surtout quand il ya un emballement
médiatique bon déjà le fait que les gens
doutent de l'institution c'est dur pour
ceux qui travaillent sans cesse pour
l'améliorer travaillé des années sur un
dossier pour qu'on fasse un tweet
méprisant sur le fait qu'on ne sait pas
faire son boulot c'est un peu rude mais
c'est peut-être ça qui fait partie du
job finalement sauf que des fois ça a
des conséquences directes sur l' enquête
je vous ai parlé de la sphère du petit
grégory un peu plus tôt c'est
effectivement l'un des premiers exemples
qui nous viennent en tête mais il y en a
plein d'autres et la faire au jour et
principalement parlé ici c'est l'
affaire d'outreau
ouh la la peur d'outreau est une affaire
très très très complexe et je n'aurai
pas le temps de vous expliquer toutes
les étapes et toutes les nuances mais
pour résumer grossièrement souvenez vous
que c'est une affaire de pédocriminalité
dans le début des années 2000 où pas
moins de dix-sept personnes sont
accusées d'abus sexuels sur mineurs
évidemment cette affaire a fait la une
des journaux ce qui est bien normal vu
la gravité des faits et surtout le
nombre de personnes concernées et on
voit encore des titres à ce sujet car
les rebondissements liés à cette affaire
ne sont pas terminés dans l' affaire
d'outreau on a reconnu que de nombreux
mineurs ont été effectivement victime de
viol d'agression sexuelle et de
proxénétisme concernant les accusés
certains ont été condamnés d'autres et
c'est la majorité d'entre eux sont
inquiétés globalement s'il ya bien une
chose sur laquelle on s'accordent c'est
le chaos juridique que représente cette
affaire judiciaire qui a mis en lumière
beaucoup de dysfonctionnements beaucoup
iront même jusqu'à parler de fiasco ou
de naufrage judiciaire
ambiance pour éviter de reproduire les
erreurs commises
une commission enquête parlementaire
s'est penché sur le sujet et pour vous
résumer en gros y'a pas un échelon qui a
pas qu'à fouiller dans cette histoire on
n'a pas respecté la présomption
d'innocence
on n'a pas été suffisamment rigoureux
dans l'analyse de témoignages le juge
d'instruction travailler seul en ayant
trop de pouvoir le manque de budget
alloué à la justice s'est fait ressentir
et la liste des couacs est encore longue
ce sur quoi on va se pencher
spécifiquement sur le rôle des médias et
du coup de la pression qu'elle engendre
je tiens vraiment à insister sur le fait
que ce ne sont pas les seuls
responsables et qui est plein de raisons
pour laquelle l' affaire d'outreau a été
un naufrage
il s'agit d'une responsabilité multiples
dont il est difficile de déterminer
exactement la part de chacun quoi qu'il
en soit les médias ont énormément manqué
de prudence sur le sujet on ne
respectons pas à présent une innocence
par exemple vous remarquerez d'ailleurs
que dans de nombreuses erreurs
judiciaires comme la sphère de patrick
dils par exemple il est pointé du doigt
a posteriori que les médias n'avait
effectivement pas respecté cette
présomption d'innocence
et cela pose un vrai problème
spécifiquement sur la fin de trop on
s'est précipité on n'a pas suffisamment
vérifier les informations et plusieurs
analystes estiment que certains
principes journalistiques et
déontologiques ont été bafoués dans son
livre la méprise édité par seuil est
sorti en octobre 2015 la journaliste
florence aubenas va rapporter qu'elle a
eu vent que le juge d'instruction
florent burgaud commettait certains
excès sauf que le juge michel gasteau va
ensuite pointé du doigt le manque de
rigueur de son ouvrage voir sa
malhonnêteté intellectuelle
effectivement florence aubenas a
rapporté des éléments faux elle a
apparemment rajouter des commentaires
corps effet le juge mais qui n'ont
jamais existé
elle a inversé la place dans la salle
d'audience des accusés et des victimes
également elle a également avancé
qu'elle avait eu accès à l'intégralité
du dossier
ce qui n'est pas possible puisque la
sphère était encore soumise au secret de
l'enquêté et ben bon courage pour
démêler le vrai du faux dans tout ça
globalement je crois que ça rend bien
compte d'une bonne confusion dans
l'esprit de chacun ce qui ne sert ni la
justice ni les accusés ou les victimes
et aggravent la crise de confiance à
l'égard des journalistes
ce qui est encore plus enquiquinant
c'est que le livre de florence aubenas
alors journaliste à libération est sorti
avant que se tienne le procès en appel
il énonce des éléments du dossier qui
pour certains sont considérés donc comme
faux et vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
lorsqu'un procès se tient devant une
cour d'assises il y à des jurés tirés au
sort sans formation de juriste
ils n'ont pas le même rôle ni le même
poids qu aux etats unis puisque ils sont
encadrés par un magistrat professionnel
mais dans ces jurés peut-être que
certains ont lu le livre de florence
aubenas peut-être que cela a pu
influencer leur décision dans un sens
comme dans un autre
et si les éléments avancés sont faux
ambiance totalement leur vision et la
potentielle décisions à venir
on n'a aucune certitude que c'est
effectivement le cas mais rien que la
possibilité puisse exister c'est déjà
trop que ce genre d' analyse après le
procès existe ne pose pas vraiment de
problème
l'affairé close il n'y a pas d'
influence sur la décision de justice
le but n'est pas de fermer le débat et
de restreindre aux seuls acteurs
judiciaires
ça ne serait pas très démocratique mais
que ce livre ait pu être publiée à
quelques semaines seulement du procès
d'appel en énonçant des choses fausses
là ça pose un très sérieux problème de
déontologie pourtant dans le code pénal
il existe un article le casse sans 34-16
qui punit la publication avant
l'intervention de la décision
juridictionnelle défini
yves de commentaires tendant à exercer
des pressions en vue d'influencer les
déclarations des témoins ou la décision
des juridictions d'instruction ou de
jugement un autre article le 434-25
incriminent la volonté de jeter le
discrédit sur un acte ou une décision
juridictionnelle lequel serait de nature
à porter atteinte à l'autorité de la
justice ou à son d'indépendance alors ne
me demandez pas pourquoi florence
aubenas n'a pas été poursuivie sur les
fondements de ces articles
c'est un mystère à mes yeux alors que
pourtant baala on est en plein dedans
à défaut de sanctions envers ce type
d'agissements qui n'est pas le seul fait
de florence aubenas il serait préférable
que certains journalistes tir eux-mêmes
des conclusions sur l' influence qu'ils
peuvent avoir sur certaines issues
d'affaires médiatisé et comme disait le
sociologue pierre bourdieu le fait
divers fait diversion bref l'idée n'est
pas de dépeindre le grand méchant médias
rempli de journal of parce que vous
savez j'ai longtemps voulu être
journaliste
alors ce serait très mal venu de ma part
je suis intimement persuadé que les
journalistes ne cherche pas à sciemment
manipuler l'opinion par tous les moyens
mais il faut être très très prudent
j'insiste dès que l'on touche aux
affaires juridiques parce que clairement
des non-spécialistes accapare souvent la
parole au détriment de professionnels
plus rigoureux on est touché par cette
affaire terrible et on a envie que notre
opinion compte en espérant pouvoir faire
évoluer la société dans le sens plus
favorable mais il faut être conscient
des limites de son expertise et de nos
connaissance du dossier pour ne pas
sombrer dans une justice populaire et ne
pas rejeter l'institution judiciaire
quand on ne sait pas exactement comment
elle fonctionne
et puis sous le régime soviétique les
journaux n'avaient pas le droit de
relayer les faits divers parce que ça
aurait pu sous-entendre qu'il y avait
des failles dans le système
donc je préfère peut-être qu'on les
relais plutôt que de trop brider la
liberté de la presse vais je pense qu'on
peut être arrivé à un juste équilibre
bref ne vous culpabilisez pas trop si
vous aimez les faits divers après tout
je dois bien vous avouer que c'est
peut-être ces articles qui m'ont poussé
à faire des études de droit parce que je
voulais comprendre plus en détail et
sans ça je ne serais pas en train de
vous parler de ça à l'heure actuelle
fait juste très attention à vos sources
sachets dompter votre attention et ne
vous couchez pas trop tard parce que
vous êtes en train de lire tous les
articles wikipedia des tueurs en série
de l'ohio et déjà fait j'étais très très
fatiguée merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à liker à la
partager sur vos réseaux sociaux à
s'abonner à la chaîne et activer la
cloche
et puis on se retrouvera sur dix corps
pour pouvoir en discuter tous ensemble
sur ce je vous dis à bientôt elle était
vraiment énervé florence à ton avis elle
est partie que ça s'est pris la tête
avec montée en passant de les réparer la
fenêtre en plus le cas ne voulait pas
qu'on arnaque un pauvre mec qui a fini à
l'hôpital parce qu'ils pensaient soigner
ses brûlures d'estomac en avalant une
roche
tu me comprends et aux femmes t'as pas
les rennais revient tout cas mon nom je
suis pas énervé je suis consterné
franchement je sais pas si je vais tenir
une semaine de plus avec vous tous ici
ça commence à faire beaucoup
[Musique]
ah non mais c'est pas du tout ce que
vous croyez que c'était pour un ami il
m'a posé des questions et je voulais lui
répondre on se retrouve sur tweets tout
de suite là maintenant en live pour
discuter de l'épisode
allez c'est parti